>> Laura: HOW IS THIS FOR
POTENTIAL BOMBSHELL?
A REPORT CLAIMS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IG, MICHAEL HOROWITZ
IS ABOUT TO ISSUE HIS
INVESTIGATIVE FINDINGS THAT
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY
WAS "BURNING A COVERT OP AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT" STARTING WITH A
PRIVATE DEFENSIVE BRIEFING HE
GAVE TRUMP WEEKS BEFORE HIS
INAUGURATION.
ENDNOTES COMEY HAD AN AGENT
INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE WHO
REPORTED BACK TO FBI AIDS.
ACCORDING TO OTHER OFFICIALS
FAMILIAR WITH THE METAL, PETER
WITH REACTION, THE HOUSE-SENATEJ
WITH REACTION, THE HOUSE-SENATED
WITH REACTION, THE HOUSE-SENATEC
WITH REACTION, THE HOUSE-SENATEA
WITH REACTION, THE HOUSE-SENATEY
LINDSEY GRAHAM, SENATOR SHOULD
HE FACED CHARGES?
IF THIS IS TRUE, WOW.
>> NOT BASED ON THE NEWSPAPER
ARTICLE BUT IF HE DID LIGHT TO
THE FISA COURT HE'S NOT ABOVE
THE LAW.
DID HE TAKE THE LAW IN HIS OWN
HANDS?
WHEN IT CAME TO TRUMP DID THEY
TAKE THE LAW IN THEIR OWN HANDS?
>> Laura: THEY FELT LIKE THEY
WERE ON DUTY.
IT SEEMS LIKE.
A VERY IMPERIOUS QUALITY.
>> THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
TWICE WITH HIS DUTY.
>> Laura: BUT RIGHT NOW, THIS
IS HOT WITH MUELLER'S TESTIMONY
ON WEDNESDAY.
THE DEMOCRATS THINK THEY WILL
GET ANOTHER BITE AT THE APPLE
AND YOU SAY?
>> I THINK THE APPLE IS DONE.
MOST AMERICANS LOOKING FOR A
MEAL OR TO TELL THEM WHAT
HAPPENED, OR NADLER.
DO YOU THINK ANY FAIR-MINDED
AMERICANS BELIEVE NATALIE WAS
OUT TO GET THE TRUTH?
HE ALREADY HAS THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS OWN MIND.
THIS IS ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
THEY IMPEACHED WITH THE MUELLER
REPORT, TRUMP WILL TAKE THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
>> Laura: YOU WERE THERE IN '
'98?
>> THAT'S HOW WE MET.
>> Laura: 90 DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE HAVE SIGNED ON TO
IMPEACHMENT, ONE REPUBLICAN.
>> HERE IS THEIR PROBLEM IF THEY
DON'T SIGN FOR IMPEACHMENT THEY
MAKE IT PRIMARY.
31 DEMOCRATS HOLD SEATS FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN THEIR
DISTRICT.
IF THEY VOTE AGAINST AOC THEY
GET A PRIMARY.
IF THEY VOTE FOR IMPEACHMENT,
THEY LOSE THEIR JOBS.
BUT I REALLY DO BELIEVE
IMPEACHMENT WOULD BE BAD FOR THE
COUNTRY AND TO GET THE PRESIDENT
REELECTED.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT THE BORDER AND JUST
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A HEADLINE
FOR THE DAY.
EVERYWHERE RICO WHAT ABOUT THE
SPORT OR SITUATION?
SECURE AND PROTECT ACT AND I
DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
LEGISLATION BECAUSE MY EYES
GLAZE OVER.
THIS COULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
YOU ARE INTRODUCING THIS
LEGISLATION VERY QUICKLY.
WHAT WOULD IT DO SO PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU HAVE TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM
IN YOUR HOME COUNTRY OF MEXICO
NOT THE UNITED STATES.
IF YOU BRING A SMALL CHILD TO
AMERICA WE HAVE MORE TIME TO
PROCESS THE CASE SO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO RELEASE THE FAMILY.
>> Laura: 20 DAYS TO OVERRIDE
THE FLORAS SITUATION.
YOU CANNOT DO IT IN 20 DAYS.
WE INCREASE THE TIME TO
ADJUDICATE THE CLAIMS IN THE --
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT TO WORK.
THEY DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH
REPUBLICANS.
AND IN THEIR OWN MINDS THEY HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY OPTED OUT OF
WORKING WITH THE REPUBLICANS
EXCEPT ON THIS OUTRAGEOUS BUDGET
WHICH I WILL ASK YOU ABOUT, BUT
TRUMP IS A RECENT SO WE WON'T
WORK WITH HIM.
HE HAS A RACIST AND PUTS KIDS IN
CAGES, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
>> AND A MILLION IMMIGRANTS,
RELEASED INTO EL PASO, SO DIDN'T
HAVE ROOM TO HOLD THEM.
IT IS JUST A MATTER OF TIME A
TERRORIST GETS IN THIS CROWD AND
COMES HERE TO HURT US.
>> Laura: WE ARE NOT SCREENING
EVERYBODY, WE CAN'T.
WE CAN'T SCREEN EVERYBODY THAT
COMES INTO THE COUNTRY.
I SAW IT WHEN I WAS THERE.
>> BORDER PATROL IS DOING A
GREAT JOB.
THIS SYSTEM IS BROKEN, IT'S NOT
A CRISIS BUT A DISASTER.
>> Laura: LINDSAY, WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE BUDGET BILL?
I GET THE PRESIDENT ON THIS
$320 BILLION IN INCREASED
SPENDING AND ONLY WHAT,
$77 BILLION IN OFFSET?
>> Laura: HE HAS A DEMOCRATIC
HOUSE THAT WILL NOT OFFSET
SPENDING.
HE HAS A MILITARY BROKEN FOR
EIGHT YEARS AND OBAMA TRYING TO
REBUILD IT.
>> Laura: THAT IS A HUGE
AMOUNT AND ABOUT FISCAL
CONSERVATISM TOO.
I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE BOTH AISLES
OF CONGRESS BUT THIS IS A
NIGHTMARE.
>> THE NUMBER ONE JOB OF PEOPLE
IN THE BUILDING DURING THE OBAMA
YEARS, WE SPENT LESS INDIFFERENT
SINCE WORLD WAR II.
THE PLANES WERE BREAKING.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE NEXT
GENERATION?
ARE THEY GOING TO PAY FOR THIS?
DO WE CARE ANYMORE?
WE ARE NOT IN DEBT BECAUSE WE
ARE DIPPING IN THE NATION BUT
BECAUSE WE MADE PROMISES WE
CAN'T KEEP SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICAID.
>> Laura: WHAT IS MEDICARE FOR
ALL DO?
WILL IT NOT BENEFIT MEDICARE
FASTER?
IT WILL DESTROY HEALTH CARE, THE
BUDGET, THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
DESTROYS THE ECONOMY AND SAVING
THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE NUMBER ONE JOB THE PRESIDENT
PREPPED THE UNITED STATES
ENEMIES FOREIGN DOMESTICALLY --
>> Laura: HE SAID HE WOULD
NEVER AGREE BUT VETO IT LAST
YEAR.
I COVERED IT ON THE SHOW.
I GOT A HOLD OF EVERYBODY
ACCOUNTABLE HERE.
HE SAID HE WOULD VETO IT.
HE IS SIGNING THIS LEGISLATION
AND APPARENTLY, IT WAS NANCY AND
CHUCK WERE A COUPLE OF PEOPLE A
GRADE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS THIS
IS THE NEW DAY.
>> THE GOVERNMENT SHUTS DOWN AND
WE DO A CONTINUED RESOLUTION.
TWO EVERYBODY LISTING --
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF --
>> THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
SACRIFICING SINCE 9/11 THE 1% TO
SERVE THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO
HAVE THEIR BACK AND FINALLY
WE'VE GOT ONE.
I WISH WE HAD THE HOUSE AND
DIDN'T HAVE TO SPEND SO MUCH BUT
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
DEFENDING THE COUNTRY, IF YOU
WANT TO FIX THE BUDGET, DO TITLE
REFORM AND I HOPE THE PRESIDENT
WILL WIN.
>> Laura: I KNOW YOU WERE
WATCHING THAT VIDEO AND WE
WRAPPED IT UP A COUPLE OF TIMES
WITH THE POLICE GETTING DOUSED
WITH BUCKETS OF WATER AND JUST
WALKING AWAY IN HARLEM BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A MIRROR
BILL de BLASIO BUT THE RESPECT
FOR THE POLICE AND THE OTHER
SIDE WE
WILL SAY, DON'T RESPECT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS BUT YOUR
REACTION TO THAT?
>> MY REACTION IS WHEN CONGRESS
WENT INTO A COUNTRY RUNNING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS AT THE
BORDER, THAT IS A SLANDER
AGAINST THOSE PROTECTING US.
>> Laura: IN UNIFORM.
>> YOU POUR WATER ON COPS DOING
THEIR JOBS, THAT IS
DISRESPECTFUL.
HOW DOES THAT STOP?
FROM THE TOP.
THAT IS WHY I'M GLAD TRUMP IS
TAKING IT TO THE FLOOR BECAUSE
THEY ARE DISRESPECTING THOSE WHO
RISK THEIR LIVES.
GO TO THE BORDER AND SEE IF YOU
WOULD WANT TO THAT JOB ONE DAY.
HOW THEY DO IT DAY IN AND DAY
OUT WITH THE THEY TAKE HIM I
DON'T KNOW.
THE PRESIDENT KEEP DEFENDING
THOSE WHO DEFEND THIS COUNTRY
INTO THE FRIENDS IN NEW YORK, IF